There's no painting in the history of
the forum,
more worthy of analysis then Diego
Velasquez,
Las Meninas,
what we're talking about here is a
master work by an artist late in his
life,
but at the height of his powers
determined to drive into this canvas,
the sum total of his talent,
his experience and his intellect.
Velasquez had been by then a court
painter for the Spanish King Phillip,
the fourth for over 30 years.
Indeed,
he was a favorite of Philips painting
his portrait many times and advancing in
salary and rank all the way up to
chamberlain of the palace,
responsible for decorating this great
Alcazar of Madrid with all its many
artworks.
So it's no surprise that for his
masterpiece,
Velasquez sets his painting in the
palace itself,
the place he knew best,
specifically in his own studio,
adorned with paintings that he himself
chose.
Now they're a little bit hard to see,
but we know what they are based on
histories of the space and it's no
accident that he chooses these paintings
specifically,
but we'll get to that a bit later.
First,
let's take a look at the main action of
the scene.
So much hits you right away.
Maybe the first thing you see is the
little girl,
Margaret Teresa,
then only living child of the king,
or maybe you see that mirror showing
reflected images of the king and queen
themselves,
or maybe the first thing that stands out
to you is that six of the nine
characters represented here are staring
beyond the picture plane,
which is to say at you that fact alone
gives this image.
It's great sense of spontaneity as if it
were Snapshot Velasquez captures the
moment just when several of these
figures are noticing something,
some like these three have yet to notice
it.
In the case of the little princess,
all that's moved so far is her eyes,
but though the moment depicted is
spontaneous,
the composition of the subjects is
anything,
but you have here a real clinic in
composing group scenes.
What Velasquez has done in this group of
11,
including the mirror images of the king
queen.
This arranged an extraordinary number of
links and contrasts that slides your
eyes back and forth across the canvas.
The first thing to notice perhaps is the
obsession here with grouping twos and
threes,
everyone here,
but the princess can be split into
pairs.
The male and female dwarf the two
chaperones here,
the curtsying made and the palace
official in the back corridor,
the king and the queen in the mirror and
Velasquez and the maid kneeling to offer
the princess a drink.
Notice also that these are all male
female pairs and these pairings
accentuate the princess as the focus of
the scene,
but you could also split the group up
into threes.
The princess with her two maids,
that dog and the two dwarves and the two
palace officials with what now occurs to
us are mirrored couples,
so you also that these two groups of
three internally made up of doubles and
triples are all on the same horizontal
plane.
This group of six also draws the
entirety of the paintings three
dimensional space.
Our eye is drawn from Velasquez and the
foreground to the palace official and
the distance as they're wearing similar
black garb and stand in line with the
two doorways on the back walls.
The chaperones in the middle ground
linked to the king and Queen in the
background,
which simultaneously brings the z axis
all the way forward beyond the picture
itself,
intimating a depth that we can't even
see.
It's amazing.
What you might not have realized is that
this motif of twos and threes has
already been established in the frames
on the back wall with two giant canvases
overtop to doorframes and the central
mirror of that bottom triple the right
sides of the frames correspond with the
princess and her two maids moving the
eyes naturally from the king and queen
to their daughter,
but the eyes are also drawn from the
mirror to the right.
That lighted passage framing the palace
official.
The space of this light and rectangle is
equal to that of the mirror and they're
put on the same horizontal plane as
well.
Indeed,
because of its brightness,
like the brightness of the little
princess bathed in light,
we're drawn to it just as much as the
other two.
In these three elements of Las Meninas,
we have three central focus points.
Unlike da Vinci's last supper,
for example,
were all elements in the painting point
toward Jesus Christ.
Las Meninas is more ambiguous letting
the viewer vacillate between multiple
centers of weight.
Being a court painter for the royal
family.
It's obvious why Velasquez would want to
highlight the royal couple and their
daughter,
but what's significant about the back
hallway?
Well,
this gets it a long running debate about
the significance of this mirror.
What exactly is it reflecting?
A number of critics have seen it as the
reflection of the actual king and queen
standing,
like we said,
beyond the picture plane,
putting the viewer literally in the
shoes of royalty,
but a closer examination of the one
point perspective of this image reveals
something else.
The vanishing point of Las Meninas is
not here,
but here in the lighted doorway to the
right.
What does this mean?
Well,
it means that the.
I have this painting,
so to speak,
isn't opposite the mirror.
What?
Opposite the door,
so the mirror doesn't reflect directly
back at us.
It reflects at an angle,
an angle that puts its image on another
unseen aspect of meninas.
The canvas that Velasquez is working on
now for a moment,
let's get back to the paintings in the
upper half of this picture.
These are copies of two paintings by
Peter Paul Rubens,
a hero of Alaska's,
and they tell similar stories in this
case,
both from ovid's metamorphosis in the
right,
the mortal Marcias challenges the god
Apollo to a flute plane contest in the
Left,
the Goddess Athena challenges the mortal
Arachni to a weaving contest.
In other words,
these are two contests between mortals
and God's on the subject of the arts,
Marcias loses and Arachni winds,
but both are punished by their gods in
the end,
for failing to recognize the divine
source of the artistic endeavor.
Such stories are extremely relevant to
las meninas because in the end,
this is a painting about painting
itself.
In Velasquez is time.
Painting still didn't hold the same kind
of noble place as poetry and music.
Las meninas in all it's splendid effects
is a vigorous argument for the virtue of
painting,
whether it comes from the heavens or
from the lifelong practice of craft,
and this gets at the heart of the
mirror.
The vanishing point and the multiple
centers of Focus,
see what my art can do for Alaska is
saying to the viewer and to his king and
Queen,
look not to nature or your own
reflection in the mirror for the most
marvelous depiction of your image,
but to my canvas,
las meninas is an extraordinary
accomplishment for its time,
but its effect is timeless.
It said that King Phillip,
the fourth,
often came to Alaska as a studio just to
watch him paint.
Somehow I think las meninas animated his
consciousness as it does mine 360 years
later.
Indeed to stare at this painting in any
age is to be convinced slowly,
gradually,
and then confidently that you are
witnessing the very best this medium has
to offer.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching and thank you to
squarespace for sponsoring this video.
Just amazing.
Like those of you who pledge on Patrion
squarespace's helping to fund this
project,
keep it going and they don't interfere
in the content,
which is awesome.
Um,
and the product is actually really
great,
sleek,
intuitive,
professional looking websites and you
don't have to know coding to make it
happen.
I'm working on something for the nerd
writer right now,
which I think is going to be pretty
cool.
Um,
and if you sign up for a year,
you can get a free domain name and if
you go to squarespace.com
and use the offer code nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
So that's pretty awesome.
You can find the link to all that stuff
in the description below.
Thank you guys for that.
And if you want to pledge to the project
directly,
you can obviously go to my patrion by
clicking right below this.
Thank you guys so much and I will see
you next time.
Next Wednesday.
Squarespace.
You should.